here's Justin Jones with his own fake
accent explaining uh well his political
philosophy I suppose
[Music]
of ousting three lawmakers your
colleagues simply because you have the
numbers to do it
if I didn't know this was happening to
us
I read the news free opposition
legislators expelled from the
legislature I would think that this was
another Nation
but no
it's Tennessee
showing to the world that democracy is
no more
John as a newsman you have to talk with
a certain Cadence
um but what is with these people who do
these fake accents and then they're off
camera and they sound like regular
people can you tell me what that's about
I I always try to give people a little
Grace and I said this week on my show
that it's true I do not sound like I
sounded in college and what changed is
that I'm on camera all the time and you
but the thing is is I don't care what he
says on camera it doesn't match what he
says off camera that's that has always
been the test of a really successful or
a quality news person in my mind you see
him on camera and then you meet him in
person is it the same person there's an
authenticity Gap in this country I talk
about it all the time uh the other guy
Justin Pearson is the one whose Clips
have gone viral or he sounds
um like you know a speech coach almost
in college and now he's talking about a
black Jesus he's got an afro and he's
certainly changed I mean that's what
happens when you get into politics right
people start to influence you you very
rarely see leaders in this country that
get into politics and remain true to
their core ideals some people change and
they change for different reasons
because lobbyists because of different
interests I I certainly think these guys
are playing to the field so to speak
they know what Their audience and what
the mainstream media for the most part
is going to eat up all I know is I hope
this really is an adjusting thing
because if I'm ever feeding Justin and
he looks at me and he's like you think I
gotta listen to you we're
gonna have a real problem
from one father to another that someday
will happen I promise you you just have
to be ready for it uh let me show you
one other thing on Justin Jones because
he's also making it sound like he's
always been this peaceful guy and he's
never done anything wrong and it's only
because of racism they're going after
him but let's play this video it's
b-roll so there's no audio so I could
talk over it for a minute this is in the
summer of love 2020. when we were all
supposed to be locked home uh you know
making sure we didn't get covered that
is Justin Jones in the Hat right there
approaching uh the car so they're
blocking the road he's one of the people
blocking the road there uh you can see
on the other side of the street watch
this guy with his little fake fall come
over there and how he's gonna oh I'm out
but watch Justin Jones he's kind of
going yelling at the guy in the car and
he's sticking his hand in the car this
guy's probably just got a truck there
he's probably just trying to go to work
now he's taking a traffic cone and he's
sticking it in the car and he's gonna
throw it at the driver who's driving
away that is very peaceful Justin Jones
if you'd like more sane takes on our
insane World check out our direct
message clips playlist and if you want
to watch more full episodes of our live
round tables watch our round tables
playlist they're both right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification Bell